un sommet des pays de l'asie du sud est
particulièrement attendu alors que la
birmanie vit au rythme des
manifestations et des affrontements ce
vendredi de nouveaux rassemblements ont
eu lieu dans le centre ville de rangoun
une situation de crise qui dure depuis
le 1er février date du renversement du
gouvernement donc sand sushi par l'armée
le bilan est particulièrement lourd
après presque deux mois de
manifestations 739 personnes ont été
tuées et trois mille trois cents autres
arrêtées selon l'association
d'assistance aux prisonniers politiques
à la tête de la junte le général mines
en ylang visé par de nombreuses
sanctions internationales participera ce
samedi un sommet spécial des dix pays de
l'association des nations du sud-est
asiatique consacré à la crise en germann
cette participation qui constituera le
premier déplacement à l'étranger du
général depuis le putsch de février est
déjà vivement critiqué par les
activistes
selon le porte parole du ministère
thaïlandais des affaires étrangères
tanis en gras c'est la crédibilité et
l'utilité même de l'asian qui se joue le
sommet devrait mettre vote selon des
diplomates
un projet de résolution appelant la
birmanie à une transition démocratique
et à libérer les dirigeants civils
nous espérons tous que ce sommet
parviendra à un accord sur les mesures
qui sont bonnes pour le peuple du
myanmar et aideront ce dernier à sortir
de cette situation délicate déjà discuté
lors de l'assemblée générale de l'onu le
vote de ce projet représenterait un
symbole politique fort temps les
condamnations internationales pleuvent
depuis le coup d'état